hello everyone my name is Ian e Lewis
and I'm right where I am
and on today's app clinic we'll be
looking at apps people use while they're
traveling that's an excellent idea
and I just would coffee on my lung oh
why don't that take the next one is the
wrong place to be drinking your coffee
Hakan are the days of badly folded maps
guidebooks and laminated holiday
itineraries today you can keep
everything you need in the palm of your
hand
that's right no longer will you look
like a bumbling tourist standing on the
corner of Oxford Street and Charing
Cross Road with your London Street Map
unfolded before you for lessly trying to
figure out which direction is Tottenham
Court you know I never even do that no
what's your plan my plan is I am always
looking at the curb in London because it
tells me which way the traffic is flow
that is very true keeping your eye on
the road is probably wise for an
American in London if you don't want to
be noted by a black cab in any case
let's face it you know when you're in a
foreign city foreign country there's a
lot to keep in your mind and yeah I
don't think my mind is big enough to
encompass at all well you want to be
able to use your mind for things like
appreciating the sights and sounds of
the new city that you're visiting not
trying to remember exactly where you be
where you need to be and how you're
gonna get there and you certainly do not
want to be unfolding a paper Mac because
that's just like a sign that says mug me
yeah please steal my stuff I have stuff
I probably have three weeks worth of
money in my pocket please rob me and
that is that it's not the message well
it's funny because you do get different
reactions in every city for instance in
in London I think they they just try and
sell you like a three-card Monte in New
York they kill you in Beijing they want
to take you to tea and then you pay for
it and in Shanghai they want to
introduce you to your sister dear sister
well introducing them to my sister would
be interesting yeah anyway I have a
sister anyway so today we're gonna be
looking at four apps that the viewers
have nominated as must-have travel
assistance apps so we're gonna be
looking at social social venue discovery
classic Foursquare the ultimate in
travel management
and one-click location sharing widget
shareware location widget excellent
so we'll be taking a closer look at each
of these apps and using them as a
kicking off point to explore the
technologies and the best practices that
you need in order to create a must-have
travel app oh that's and more on the app
clinic so a travel assistance is a
pretty broad category and that's been
reflected in the three apps that we'll
be looking at today as part of the
developer relations team at Google
Travel is a big part of our job for it
used to be before we got this boss video
studio the the video studio that puts
that thing in back of us oh hey so this
is a category that we are intimately
familiar with I've been traveling for
work for what 10 years now and it could
be a nightmare it's also one of the more
popular groups of apps in Google Play
and the popular apps in this category
tend to have very loyal and passionate
users take for example Foursquare mm-hmm
so let's say let's have a look oh look
at that beautiful now this isn't a
travel app per se but it's it's
definitely useful as a travel app I
think you had some insights into that
right yeah absolutely let's uh let's see
you want to put that in front in fact uh
yeah yeah just I remember had this was
supposed to work now yes excellent so
when I was growing up in Australia
Foursquare was the name of an
independent group of supermarkets whose
TV ads implored me to come in for square
deal so every time I look at this app I
hear the jingle playing in my head
leaving that aside I'm a big fan of
Foursquare both for the service and the
features that they offer as well as
their passion for creating a really
great user experience which is a really
important thing we can see that over the
course of the years the Foursquare app
has really progressed as each version of
Android has come out they've refreshed
the UI they've taken advantage of some
of our best practices so this is an app
that that I'm a really big fan of
now strictly speaking you don't need to
be traveling for Foursquare to be useful
in a lot of ways it's most useful when
you're close to home doing your daily
routine and a lot of people whose coffee
shop loyalty is based around fierce
competition to maintain their status as
an heir of Pete's coffee shop on the
corner of El Camino and San Antonio
roads now a big part of Foursquare
success is also around the social
elements of its use isn't as indicated
by this screenshot it's a way to share
where you are let you know where your
friends are hanging out and all those
sorts of things
but for today we're gonna be focusing on
its use while you're on the road and
that's where I found it to be the most
compelling when I'm away from home on a
trip there's really no chance I'm going
to become the mayor of anything except
for maybe the hotel that I'm staying at
so the apps primary use case switches
from sort of consistent use of the same
venues to discovery and exploration now
this is the part that I really wanted to
hear about because I have avoided
Foursquare for another first because it
was a hipster app and second because I
just couldn't see the use in being a
mayor I felt I'm the kind of person
who's so ultra competitive that I avoid
competition just so I don't have to lose
that's pretty hardcore I like it uh-huh
so when I lived in London I'd visit the
the mothership here at Google every
three months or so and as soon as I
landed in SFO and checked into the
terminal it was game on coffee shops
hotels restaurants hotdog stands pretty
much anything I I used to travel with
well I think only once or twice with
Nick and Richard and those guys would be
on the Cal train checking into each Cal
train stop as they went past it so as
far as competition goes this guy's a
pretty hardcore
so the thrill of rocketing up the
leaderboard is a short-term gain
although what I really makes this app a
tribal assistance powerhouse is its
discoverability features so back in I
can't even remember when it was
2009-2010 whenever the Nexus One came
out I went on a 10-day European Roadshow
where we hit something like nine cities
in ten days staying in each one just
long enough to get a good night's sleep
hand out a couple hundred Nexus ones and
grab a meal so suddenly and we don't do
that anymore by the way we are you know
I hand out phones
anymore because sadly it was a lot of
fun it was an easy way to make friends
in foreign cities right it's like being
the those GIS in World War two with
their chocolate and cigarettes exact
they love me everywhere I went they
loved me
nice yeah I'm sure it had nothing to do
with the giveaways so suddenly having an
app that tells you where you can get a
good meal and rewards you with points
for doing so really becomes very
appealing so I'm gonna go into more
detail as to how the social discovery
service on a Foursquare works a little
later on but first let's take a look at
TripIt indeed oh wow
it's totally covered up okay oh right
right we're supposed to do it this way
huh I love
TripIt by the way I should mention that
rato fracing loves TripIt I do I love
them but I I don't frakking love it
because it's not 2008 anymore when I
start going up herbs I didn't even have
a cell phone
much less a smartphone I had to manually
create my own version of TripIt with
printouts of bookings and receipts and
flight itineraries and maps to my
apartment and maps of the Train and I
kept doing this for years when I worked
for Microsoft they tried to do it with a
Windows Mobile Phone that didn't work
out so well nothing against that well
okay anyway uh later on I switched to an
iPhone and then when I came here I
switched to an Android phone but
honestly the experience was still
unsatisfying and the most important
problem was that my itineraries would be
in my email and I'd have to make sure a
that it was synced to the right folder
in my email and be that it synced and
remained synced and didn't get tossed
out by by the time I needed it so I
would frequently find myself in line for
let's say a rental car frantically
charging my phone off of my laptop
battery pack just so I could bring up an
email that told me where and when I was
supposed to be at a certain place at
this point though I don't have to do any
of that with TripIt I can just set it up
to go through my email and find all of
the travel rated related stuff although
it turns out that the security guys at
Google don't like that so I just stopped
that before
only what you can do is set up an email
forwarding rule just take everything yet
from I don't know you know Expedia or
Carlson Wagonlit or the other places
that we use to book travel and just
forward it on to trip it and trip it
will actually figure out what the email
means it'll pull out all of the details
about your hotel and about your flights
and then it will store that and send you
reminders
whenever you whenever you need them so
by the time I'm sitting in the taxi view
or the airport I've got my entire trip
right in front of me
hotels weather cars directions even
information about what friends of mine
the youth trip that are going to be in
the same place at the same time for me
the most exciting part about trip it is
just the way it seems to work like magic
everything just appears it comes up when
it should it lets me know what time I
need to be where it figures out where I
am and where I need to be and it works
offline without having to connect up to
an Internet which is really really
important as you're traveling because a
lot of times internet access is either
unavailable or incredibly expensive it
also does some clever clever things with
intense and rachel is going to be going
over that a little bit later but before
we do that it's time to take a quick
look at haha we got to take a look at
share where widget nice handoff that was
beautiful I thought it was really clean
I'm gonna start to move over to this
site because I know they were gonna be
in frame now just suppose like a moment
to comment on the Google Play landing
page for share where location widget I
really love their icon here it's got
that distinctive shape that provides a
really strong branding and even a hint
as to what the app does without sort of
resourcing to that sort of square with
rounded corners that you see right
domain should they have a great icon and
it doesn't have a background love it
exactly it's also great to see that
they've got a feature graphic but here I
think they could take another pass at
this the feature graphics are really
used in a lot of different places
including on the phone not always at
this massive size and resolution that
you can see here so a graphic like this
that includes a lot of text is going to
be pretty illegible when it gets shrunk
down into their smaller sizes so I'd
suggest that you rely on the description
field which is just
to detail the functionality of the app
and really make the feature graphic a
little more stylized in the same way
that you've got this great logo icon
make it more like that so that you sort
of just giving an idea of the app rather
than trying to explain everything within
a small feature graphic you know what
this feature graphic says to me what
does it say it says they hired it as a
great designer and he made a great icon
and then like the CEO put together the
feature graphic we've got everything we
need we don't have to pay and pay
another guy a couple of grand to create
the feature graphic exactly I've got
Photoshop exactly so yeah maybe make it
look like a designer did the feature
graphic as well I think that's service
really gonna help you out and just gives
you that much more professional feel and
now if we actually look at the app
itself in terms of functionality this is
a much simpler maybe you would even say
sort of tired of focus than either of
the other apps we're looking at today so
the idea here is a pretty simple one it
lets you create a home screen widget or
a number of home screen widgets which
will send preset messages to one or more
recipients and those messages can go out
via SMS email or actually using any app
that you like using intents it's a
simple concept and one which are
actually considered writing a while back
an app I called
one-click SMS which you know had a very
similar idea sort of I just wanted to
always tell my wife I'm on my way home I
was on my way home
without having to try and do all the
sloppy stuff just press a button and
it's exactly what this what this app
does so I love the idea of having a
OneTouch emergency widget on my home
screen to let me you know let friends
and family know that I've survived the
inevitable San Francisco earthquake or
that I'm and then I could at that end
I'll try that again and that I'm okay or
that I'm not okay and having my location
embedded within that message that they
know we're in the rubble to dig through
I think would be really useful as well
as things like I've arrived safely my
flights just landed I'm on my way home
any of those sorts of things so being
able to do all of that really quickly
without having to scroll through
contacts lists or try and type in a
keyboard while I'm walking you know
half-asleep or jet-lagged is really a
plus there's some UI work that we could
be done to improve the UX and I'll go
into a little bit more detail on that
later but they've done some great work
in terms of keeping the functionality
simple and using intents to make
even more powerful without having to do
much extra work so the best thing that
they've done is keep it simple and an
app that does one thing and it does it
very well love it so each of these apps
offers some valuable features to help
you when you're traveling taking step
back let's take a look at the key
features we're looking for in a pure
Android travel assistance app ok so the
the feature the feature set of each of
these apps are kind of orthogonal
they're all really useful for travelers
but there's very little overlap right so
that's handy because it helps focus on
how they're achieving some of that
magical feature set rather than debating
the relative merits of each features
exactly so each of these apps needs
needs to work when when I'm away from
home right because their travel app sets
the whole point and so that means that
I'm likely to be charging my phone less
often so battery life and battery
consumption becomes really important
data transfer is likely to be slower
it's probably going to be roaming so
it's probably going to be expensive so
back home I may not care suddenly I'm in
Italy I'm paying a lot more for my
roaming costs so I care about what data
transfer and frankly I'm probably gonna
be turning it on and off depending on
what I need stuff at the same time a lot
of times when you're traveling you will
get great data every now and then like
when you've got Wi-Fi right exactly so
you know in Italy for instance they have
Wi-Fi on the trains if you hook up
they're not they have whiffy on the
trains oh I'm sorry yeah in Italy is all
whiffy right swim pond the Bobby exactly
anyway the point is that you're you're
not just having nonexistence data or
expensive data you're having very
intermittent data so when you do have
Wi-Fi or wee-fee or waffle or whatever
it is you probably want to take the most
advantage of that exactly and of course
location is key it's particularly
important because you want to know where
you are but this has to be balanced
around the fact that you don't want to
be draining the battery getting those
location updates all the time so it's
really a balancing act of wanting to
have fresh data having constant data
working offline accurate location
without draining the battery when you
know chances are you going to have your
phone you're going to be using it a lot
but you're only going to be charging it
at the end of every
so the final result really does emphasis
the emphasize the efficiency of apps
serving this market so last year's i/o
Rachel spent a bunch of time talking
about how to ensure your app is always
fresh which is extremely important for
apps is that an android using deodorant
it is to maintain freshness silly person
let me yes don't smell I'm just gonna
pop that in front so everyone can see
the other the link to the to the
presentation as well indeed yes it was
all about freshness you know not just
about androids using deodorant but but
also you know this is really important
for apps like Foursquare and TripIt
we're in these types of situations
latency is your enemy particularly if
you're looking at late for a train or
you know you just tired after a long day
of sightseeing you just want to find
somewhere to eat what you don't want to
do is spend a lot of time waiting for
your phone to refresh to find a
connection to download information you
just want to have everything at your
fingertips so that you can glance on it
and and keep running basically so let's
take a look at some look of Foursquare
for detail all right so let me bring up
the giant phone Jo fateful right perfect
so you can see that the Foursquare has
done a fantastic job on I'm pretty much
everything they've created something
that's really engaging really
interesting really great to look at
they've got a modern-looking UI you can
look at a straightaway and you can see
that it feels like a modern you know a
modern Android phone it's all using holo
theming all of that good stuff and it's
what's really useful here is that what
were what ian is experimenting with here
is that the local search feature which
we were discussing beforehand and that's
kind of the key here so you can see as
we go through here it's got the map it's
showing where your friends are so if
you're traveling in a group which is
something we used to do a lot of things
like Google developer days and death
fests you can see where other people
that you're traveling with are at you
know where where's everyone going out
for a drink after the conference is
finished you can track them all down you
can find places that other people have
raided perhaps on previous trips so it's
it's really a way for you to be able to
get some idea of confidence as to you
know where should I go
you know I just want to grab a meal I'm
in a place that I'm not familiar with
you know what's a good place is is there
anywhere which is recommending in the
nearby neighborhood that you would agree
or disagree with
oh absolutely Cafe Blais place is great
excellent cafe uh-huh so that's a good
choice that they've have selected there
actually and you can go through and this
sort of consistent clean UI is pervasive
throughout the entire app it shows you
the information that you want address
details who's checked in photos all of
that sort of information and does it you
know in a really clean natural way again
what I really like about this is the
simplicity it keeps everything really
simple shows you the information that
you need without sort of making an
overly complicated UI so it really is
something that's easy to use and quite
addictive I think you know if you don't
have this mountain of information I
think that's a challenge for a lot of
apps like this is that there are a lot
of venues around so you know there's
this tendency to just drop a thousand
pins on the screen at any given time and
that's not actually really useful what
you want to know is where do I want to
go and this is somewhere where choice
can be a problem if I'm standing on
Castro Street I know there's a bunch of
restaurants around I want to know which
one I should go to based on the things
that I like that my friends have checked
into and those sorts of things that's
something Shecky they do a really good
job off absolutely and just as a side
note you can see that the design here is
really beautiful and they've done some
of the things that we've talked about
you know putting your your media front
and center making sure that you you you
know make good use of space every time
something is blank it's it's for a
reason but mostly just bringing up these
beautiful beautiful pictures absolutely
I mean that's what this is all about I
mean what Foursquare has which a lot of
other apps which are offering similar
services don't is a huge community of
people which are contributing to the
information here so we have lots of
pictures contributed by users which you
can trust because it's not the picture
that the owner has taken on the day
where it's cleared out everyone and you
know given everything is spic and span
clean its features which people have
taken while they've been hanging out
there so they've done a really good job
so what I want to talk about a little
bit is use this basically as an excuse
to talk a little bit about how
Foursquare have done the job that they
have done
so there's it's it's kind of simple
enough to get location updates for
Android but what Foursquare have done a
really good job of is making sure that
that location updates are as low latency
as possible so there's a few tricks that
you can use to maintain your location
freshness without draining the battery
completely so you can significantly
reduce the battery oh sorry you can
significantly reduce the latency for
getting your first location fix by
retrieving the last-known location from
the location manager each time the app
is resumed so if you have a look at this
code snippet not much just pop that in
front as well so you can perhaps read
that a little bit more easily
so in this snippet we're going to
iterate through each location provider
on the device including those that
aren't currently available and we're
going to seek out the most timely and
most accurate last-known location so if
there's one one or more locations
available from within the allowed
timeframe then we can return the one
which has the most accurate result and
if there isn't then we return the most
recent result though if we're just doing
that the most recent result but it's
kind of beyond our latency window it's
pretty good practice to request a single
location update from every available
provider to try and get a more recent
result at this point it it doesn't even
matter which is the more accurate result
you just want to get something that's a
little more timely so that you get
something which is in the vaguely
correct location and then obviously you
can continue to do your location updates
to try and get something even more
useful so one thing that I've always
wanted to ask you right now about
location cuz I know you're kind of the
location guy so I remember when when I
first started traveling this is way back
in the Dark Ages when we didn't have
offline maps and we didn't have really
good location providers and I found an
app called maverick that was mostly for
geocaching and so they they made it work
in the wilderness nice and it turned out
that for me anyway coming from the US
London was effectively so what it did
was it allowed me to download a bunch of
map tiles which may or may not have
actually been illegal uh it downloaded
in regardless in the
and then it it would find GPS but it
also kept track of my location through
dead reckoning mm-hm and does it do any
of the phones we we have now do that
automatically is that part of the
location provider not that I'm aware of
no I think the the location providers
that we're using at the moment are
fairly simplistic in that it's just GPS
or a network network location what do we
call the NLP Network here a network
location provider so using sort of cell
ID and Wi-Fi rather than sort of
momentum and dead reckoning and those
sorts of things though I think that's
something which the industry is heading
towards right so it'd be fantastic to
see more and more of those sorts of
features become part of the location
providers available
wouldn't it be great how no what
implications does that have for power
though well I guess that's kind of the
question and that's one of the important
reasons why within Android you shouldn't
be specifying a particular location
provider so at the moment it's just
assumed that GPS is going to drain your
battery and the network location
provider is going to be relatively low
power but these days it's actually
becoming a point where a lot of the GPS
chips are becoming more and more power
efficient and getting built into the
hardware itself so the actual location
drain is significantly lower by
comparison the network location
providers are using a lot more features
things like gyroscopes things like you
know momentum all those things which can
comparatively increase its battery drain
so what it then means is that it's kind
of up to the system to figure out how to
balance those things and provide you as
an accurate result as you can without
draining the battery and so you know for
us right now that means using things
like criteria to specify a location
provider based on the power drain or the
or the accuracy you need rather than
saying hey I think that this implies
that so I'm going to use that particular
provider so as with many things Android
you really don't want to go to low level
yourself because you know that things
are gonna get better and they're gonna
get better in a very unpredictable way
we're on some devices they're much
better in terms of power for instance
and other devices they haven't made
those changes so you're always safest
going with the basic system and then if
you absolutely have to
it tweak things for specific classes of
devices maybe you want to do that
exactly a good example is you're
creating a device which lets you
understand how many GPS satellites
you've got in view and we looked at a
couple of these apps a little while ago
sort of these GPS apps clearly they want
the GPS provider whether it's accurate
or draining the battery or whatever they
don't really care that's not the point
for everything else you want to be as
high level as possible and then trust
that as the framework team are able to
make improvements to these API is that
suddenly your app will get better and
more efficient and more accurate with
you are you actually having to do
anything right yeah I think this is a
good area if you're doing a location out
stay tuned and make sure you follow not
only Android but the the different
chipset vendors and see what kind of
changes they're making because I know
there's a lot of active research in this
area absolutely I think we've been
hearing a lot about things like sort of
passive background location updates and
you can see apps like Google now in fact
being able to give you sort of these
really cool hints about how far you've
walked or you know suggesting things
based on your location and those sorts
of stuff so it's kind of cool I'm going
to talk a little bit about how you can
do some of those things in just a minute
great let's do that so generally I
prefer to use pending intents rather
than location listeners when I'm making
my location request and that's because
it offers the flexibility of registering
receivers in multiple activities or
services or even directly in the
manifest and in fact by doing that you
can make your app silently update the
location just like what we mentioned and
potentially even update the list of
nearby venues so an app like Foursquare
can sort of passively listen for these
location changes and then in the
background every once in a while
actually pull down nearby location so
when you open the app you're not waiting
for that in sort of feeling like it's
interminable come on yeah I was there
half an hour ago I'm here now just give
me something you know more more
reasonable well and let's remember too
that while you're doing this it's very
very important to persist that
information because your pending intents
and you know any listener of this type
is gonna be running in the background
which means that if the user let's say
boots off a game or starts to run out of
battery you're gonna be on the list to
be killed and if you're keeping that
information in memory then it's going to
go away and essentially you've just
wasted
power for nothing so make absolutely
sure that that gets persisted out to
either a content provider or your own
file system database or whatever yeah
she had references can be a good one for
there you go yeah exactly exactly so now
requesting location updates particularly
if you're using something like GPS
anything which is sort of high power
while your app isn't in the foreground
is kind of a bad idea it's going to
drain the battery it's going to make
people angry so what you're going to do
instead is use a passive location
provider to piggyback your location
updates when other apps are requesting
them so again I'm going to pop the code
in front so you can see in this code
snippet we request location updates
using a passive provider this thing in a
broadcaster pending intent whenever it
receives any of those changes and it
includes a receiver definition as well
down the bottom which is what you put in
your manifest which is then going to
listen for those broadcast intents in
order so that you can then do something
with them so within our receiver
definition we can choose what to do when
those new locations come in which may be
store the location for later use though
often that's going to be duplicating the
work that you can do just by querying
the get last-known location or you can
do other things like prefetching nearby
locations when certain conditions are
met so you may want to do that much less
frequently than the updates that you are
receiving exactly now the door is just
open at Billy's sticking his head in so
there's something wrong with the show
What's Wrong Billy no Oh outstanding
beautiful he's just making sure we're
actually doing work we're not just
sitting in here drinking exactly I
respect your I respects his confidence
in us absolutely so uh let's move on so
uh wow that's an entirely blank screen
very disconcerting Mike Wynn don't ever
stick your head in again you screwed up
everything so the this technique of
prefetching can be really powerful but
it's also inherently risky as you're
introducing a battery and bandwidth cost
by downloading data that may never
actually be necessary so if you're
looking at a travel assistance app that
can be kind of touch-and-go and that's
something which I think Foursquare are
really aware of you know and this is an
app where again you know that balance
between being an app that you use
at home and an app that's really useful
when you're away becomes kind of an
interesting balance of how do you
maintain that freshness without draining
the battery and becoming something which
people don't want to have running when
they're overseas well I think this
actually starts to get into the secret
sauce of what makes an app truly amazing
and what what it means you know for
instance we've talked about this with a
video apps where everybody and their
brother uses some some form of media
player on any platform but you know
flash player on the web for instance but
where the secret sauce comes in is how
do you make something start really fast
and play at a good bandwidth and switch
bandwidth easily and in location apps
it's really how do you know when a
person's going to try and use it and if
you look at what we've done with Google
now it really tries to predict based on
your past behavior what you're going to
need at a particular point and I think
that when you look at Foursquare you're
seeing some of those smarts and some of
those and tells you something you could
probably even go further and make it
into something where you kind of know
when the app is going to be needed
because you can see where the user is
and you know even how fast they're going
and what time of day it is and predict
what the what kind of information
they're going to need absolutely so
another useful best practice is
monitoring the state of your providers
all right so this is kind of important
so when you make a location update
request even when you're using criteria
the location manager is just going to
choose one of those providers whose
updates it's going to monitor so
whatever provider happens to be active
with that the user has GPS ticked or the
network location provider ticked it's
going to try and make a determination
based on what's available but that can
change in real-time so again I'm going
to stick this code ya know stick this in
front then I can move around a little
bit more alright so this snippet is
monitoring two conditions it's checking
to find out the location provider that
we're using to Seavers being deactivated
so user can turn these on and off so
it's checking to make sure that okay
we've decided to use GPS and the user
goes and turns off GPS we're going to be
able to then find another provider and
likewise we're going to check to see if
there is another provider that becomes a
so maybe we would have used GPS but it
was disabled and then it gets turned on
we want to switch without the user
having to exit the app and come back in
or manually do something that way it
should all happen dynamically so in
either case we just going to rerun the
process used to determine which provider
that is currently available is best for
our current needs and this technique
ensures that we can continue to receive
location updates without interruption
either even if the user is toggling GPS
and network location provider details so
that's interesting
I'm sure that there was a sure that
there was a picture behind this
nonetheless you can find all of these
tips in great detail in the deep dive
into location blog post that is actually
on the next page boom I am so sorry I
fixed almost all of those that's okay
but nonetheless so this is a blog post I
wrote mid last year I think and even
created a sample project that includes
the basic Foursquare functionality so
you have to do two jumps there we go for
finding nearby venues so this is
displaying them in a list allows you to
check in using Google Places API which
you can find here so that's basically
it's all all the sorts of things that we
were talking about all those best
practices around using passive location
provider monitoring location provider
changes and being able to make sure that
you're doing everything in the
background an intelligent way that
hopefully isn't going to drain your
battery now TripIt the need for
freshness is a little more different so
the important thing about TripIt is and
let's bring up the giant fake phone
shall we no of course yeah so with with
TripIt you're gonna have and now you
don't have any any actual plans in here
but I noticed that some of your friends
do well like I was gonna go back to trip
that I eat I think it's already easier
in fact let me let me navigate through
that you go to pause trips the idea with
trivet is that it's all of your travel
information in one place and it's going
to show you the most relevant thing
first and try and remove all the
irrelevant nonsense
so it needs to know what time it is and
it needs to know where you are hmm
so in in this particular case for
instance knowing that we're going from
Melbourne to Perth is only important if
we are not in Perth
yeah and you could find that in two
different ways right and so you could
you can find that out either through
location or by time but probably the
location is a little safer because the
light may have been delayed a month or
may have missed the flight indeed same
thing with the hotel since have
everything you know the idea is once
you've got there you don't need to see
it anymore so it doesn't need to be
updated
perhaps as frequently as as Foursquare
does and but it does need to update at
least in time to be able to show and
hide this information exactly and one of
the other things which I think is really
important is it needs to be able to
update you know the sort of this balance
because if something does change if my
flight time changes or my hotel booking
changes I need to see that updated
straightaway and that needs to be as low
latency as possible but the frequency of
that it's pretty rare you know it's not
once the travel is booked
it's you're gonna be lucky if there's a
change once a day if that indeed you
certainly don't want to be checking
every five minutes to see if your
flights delayed instead what you really
want is to know exactly when your
flights delayed and then never worry
about it again right so if I was doing
this with just my airline my airlines
gonna send me an SMS to let me know that
the flights delayed now I don't want
TripIt to send me an SMS because there's
a better way to do that right absolutely
you want yeah exactly
in fact I think what we want is to
hopefully what it does is use GCM
exactly so let's let's have a look at
some of the things which should be able
to do and do really well so knowing
where we are is important but it's much
more important that I get my itinerary
changes as quickly as possible and as I
mentioned let me see if I can
drop this behind us Anita well that
looks a bit weird nonetheless home but
this does set up a conflict and and like
we said it's it's that idea of you know
we want things to happen straight away
but we don't wanna have to do these
manual updates and so what that does is
that we have I love these graphs that
you make because they're they're
complete nonsense and to the right
height up and to the right so it's it's
a good graph right do the obvious graphs
people uh-huh so it's it's again it's
this how do we reduce the latency but
but not have that increase in battery
life and that's generally what happens
is that the the fresh of the data is the
more battery cost and why you actually
want to be somewhere down here where you
have right
it's God's monkey dance the reason I'm
dancing instead of sharing technical
information is because I was sick
yesterday script this whole show himself
and he's only been a little bit bitter
about it rain down a little um so even
if you're not downloading anything every
time you do the poll you're still
potentially draining the battery and
that's because of the way that the the
the battery life cycle model works so I
should say the cell network life cycle
of the cell radio I which is going to
stay on high power for around ten
seconds and along around low power for
kind of up to a minute every time you
ping a server even though the server's
going it's cool nothing you need to do
still going to do to drain the battery
so if you're you know doing these
updates every minute then yous leaving
the cell radio on permanently which is
going to destroy your battery life and
so this is compounded by the typical
update rates of apps like TripIt where
if my antenna changes I want that update
like now like as soon as it happens but
it's not going to happen that often so
how can we optimize those updates and
minimize the latency well in fact and
the most important answer is to use
Google Cloud messaging like seriously
use Google Cloud messaging it is going
to solve most of these problems it's
something which TripIt as far as I can
tell has done because there is that
option to choose manual slash push and I
have a look in their manifest and they
are using those things but they still
have the options for those more frequent
updates so I kind of want to hear from
the guys at rip it and find out you know
are you using it exclusively if not why
not
and is there a reason for still having
that option to do the manual poling
which is just going to drain the battery
well there was a time when Google Cloud
messaging was c2dm and there was a there
was a cab all right you could only send
somebody message today now that's that's
not a place anymore hmm so it may be
that in the past it was difficult for
them to guarantee that they wouldn't hit
their c2dm limit that could well be the
case now of course see Google Cloud
messaging isn't doing anything magical
it's just taking advantage of the fact
that a lot of apps want to do this sort
of thing and so it makes a lot more
sense to coalesce that into one ping
that's done intelligently with batter
life in mind rather than having everyone
ping their servers at whatever time they
feel like exactly so it's a way that you
can send a message to a particular
device or set of devices used by a
particular user informing the app
running on that device that there's
updates which they need to retrieve so
the result is near instant updates with
none of the battery drain or at least
your app doesn't get blamed for any of
the battery drain caused by grate which
we would normally get with regular
polling so you get to blame it all on
Google which is much cooler right if
anyone's going to get blamed for battery
drain it may as well be the system
rather than your app if you can so it's
kind of a no-brainer
similarly you'll want to prefetch as
much data as possible and it's
particularly important for an app like
TripIt and it's something that they do
really well in that I had to think about
whether or not they did which made me
realize that they must because otherwise
I'd have thrown through a window um so
you know offline access here is
absolutely vital for a lot of travel you
know particularly when we were just sort
of jumping from country to country you
don't have the opportunity to buy a
local sim just for the data which you
know we often you often do if you're
gonna be there for a week or so if
you're gonna spend 12 hours you're just
gonna have you Corp global roaming sim
and you're going to disable data a lot
airports it often takes a long time once
you get out of flight mode for the data
connection to start back up and I want
to know where to tell the driver the
taxi driver to go without having to you
know wait for half an hour for my phone
to turn on them to find Wi-Fi in order
to be able to get those updates
so for apps like Foursquare though
prefetching can be tricky so that
because there's there's no knowing which
places user is going to want to check in
to or what areas or categories they're
going to want to explore it you can't
prefetch everything because that would
just be a huge battery drain and a huge
bandwidth drain particularly if you're
roaming so prefetching can be kind of a
cat-and-mouse game between trying to get
the right details without wasting too
much bandwidth so for apps like TripIt
where the information users want is
relatively small
well encapsulated around a trip and
entirely predictable you know you know
you even know when they're going
traveling so you can wait to do the
prefetching until the day before pull it
all down stick it on the device and then
it's just there and it's just working so
you can go into offline airplane mode
and all still works so in that in that
instance I think prefetching
be really really powerful along the same
lines it's really important that you
limit bandwidth as much as possible and
that means caching results particularly
images or anything that's likely to
remain static better still your servers
server should specify the lifetime and
update timestamps of its responses and
that's what you can see in this piece of
code I'm just going to step back from
rather than for a full screen so in this
code snippet we're just checking the
server response headers to see if we
actually need to bother downloading the
rest of the response body so this is
still gonna cost you in terms of hitting
the server for to see whether there's
anything to get but at least you're not
then downloading extra data that you
already have whether it hasn't changed
since the last time you ping the server
if it's possible to look at how to and
determine how fresh each piece of data
is that's really useful because in a lot
of apps I would much rather know that a
piece of data is stale then to not see
it at all and see a loading bar problem
where it's dead
absolutely so can all it's probably also
worth mentioning that network state and
the type of network that you're
connected to can can also be really
important in determining the frequency
of your data transfers and the
aggressiveness of your prefetching so
you can actually monitor all of that as
you can see in this code snippet well
we're checking the server response
headers that doesn't seem true so in in
this lip of what we're doing is
modifying the size of the prefetching
cache depending on the network speeds
we're going to increase it when we're on
Wi-Fi or on 4G or we're going to drop it
down when more are slower networks and
so again all we're doing here is trying
to find a better balance between battery
drain and and a latency reduction so I'm
gonna go or I do go into much more
detail on this on you know in on how to
create apps which are more efficient in
my eye o talk from earlier this year
which is the link here it's a bitly
slash pro tips 2 and and there are more
details on creating efficient download
patterns in this Android training class
as well
Oh tips by the way to JJ Abrams make
that for you did yeah yeah I know a guy
haha so a fine let's take a closer look
at shareware which is era a third app
that's share aware of course not just
shareware could be sure where I think
it's just share wet
oh it's where with like where hominins
right in its share where yeah I'm sure
we're not sure where right
no don't share this app that will be
piracy and that would be bad wonderful
now unlike fistful hon like fair square
I'm like Foursquare and TripIt shareware
which is what I've written there was
self nominated and isn't yet an editor's
choice on Google Play and so we're gonna
try and be a little bit more nuts on it
yeah so we're gonna try and be a little
more constructive let's say constructive
there you go exactly um cuz you know you
put your app up here I'm gonna steam
that you you want to have our our
feedback oh you wouldn't boss for it but
our goal is till to set it up to bring
it up to a standard where we can show it
off to everyone else in our pure Android
collection so that's yeah that's pretty
much the goal for any app that we look
at here we want to bring it up to
something which we can show off to
everyone else well in read each asset in
your in your morbid preamble this is an
app that has great functionality that's
something that we really want to own but
maybe not in this exact form yeah
exactly so we're gonna give the
developer a chance to share their
experiences and implementing some of our
suggestions and you know if you've been
explaining some of the choices that
they've made in later episodes of
developers strike back so stay tuned for
that
but so let's have a look at the app
that's do so the the thinking behind
this app is pretty straightforward let's
just bring the giant phone up so the
idea here is that you're going to create
a bunch of home screen widgets which all
have predefined messages which you can
set to a predefined audience so in case
of emergency or you know I've just come
home I've just landed any of those
things so you can do it all ahead of
time now what happens when you load the
app up the first time is you get this
massive screen of options now it is a
widget app and there is a challenge
associated with widgets apps in that you
can't just have
the main launcher icon launch the app
widget selector so you have to find a
way to add meaningful value in that when
you when you first open up the app and
that's a challenge that we see a lot of
widgets apps do and so a lot of them
will do this go straight into the
configuration screen which isn't a bad
idea except as you could see it's kind
of a complicated options menu there's a
huge number of options there some
information in there as well as some
actual settings there's help about
contact us little tech fields which just
explain what the app does and it becomes
a little bit overwhelming for a
first-time Musial's like this needs more
than anything is a tutorial sure it
really does need a little animated
tutorial with little back in next
buttons and that's can I just get button
yes you know little little pictures of
fingers and things like that yeah needs
to because you need to help people
understand this is an incredibly useful
piece of functionality that a lot of
people are gonna want especially people
who are not particularly computer
literate so they may or may not know
where to find widgets and Android but
they certainly know how to or certainly
know what they want the app to do
absolutely and they just need to be told
how to do it that's right and so what
you can see on the on the home screen
here is the end result of placing these
widgets so you can see that we've got a
we've got different sized widgets so
this is a one by one we've got a two by
two by one here as well and if we click
resize they do have a resizable one as
well um so there's a third off which I
actually thought I'd dropped on here but
maybe maybe I hadn't we taught you to a
resizable one in fact we can we can
bring it up on widgets yeah well I just
smelled another business opportunity I
get I could do homescreen launcher
widgets like this and go for Metro
absolutely so you can see here actually
so this is the four by one which is
actually resizable and you can see again
this is the configuration screen for
each of the widgets now straightaway the
UI is a little it could use a little
work let's say it looks kind of
gingerbready it's got the black theme
which i think in this instance doesn't
really work because you've kind of just
feels like it's blending into the
background because it is and it isn't
fullscreen either and i can kind of see
why they haven't gone fullscreen because
they want it to look like it's a
configure
dialogue but I think in this instance
you could actually benefit from actually
launching a full activity which just you
go into you set things up you hit save
or okay or whatever and your
configuration is complete yeah and even
if you are going to do a full screen or
were not full screen dialogue it should
be prettier than absolutely you know
part of this is on us right I mean
orange on black was cool for like five
months back in 2010 so it's claimed it's
over so yeah we all like blue now right
and you can see I mean we'd like to blue
before actually do that's true
nobody likes orange no-one likes orange
and you can see straight away why this
kind of creates issue it's like straight
away it looks kind of weird and then if
I click this so they've done the right
thing here in that it does launch the
contact picker to let you to choose
which contact you want to want to
include but this is all holy things Wow
this is Daniel's phone one of Daniels
friends is Daniel awkward so you can't
get this to cognitive dissonance of like
well I'm definitely not in the same app
anymore alright well I don't know what's
going on here but you know if you click
through then and again you you know you
be brought in bringing up this kind of
weird non Hollow non modern UI designer
mix of styles exactly so you really want
to try and find a way to use sort of the
default themes so that you're keeping up
with whatever style is prevalent at the
time on whichever device is installed it
also feels like this this could use more
graphics yeah something that's sort of
explanatory like I would even imagine
maybe you know a little view pager is
something that chooses different types
of widgets with graphics that represent
each of them you know Joe's thing that
you're going to want to do maybe even
have a bunch of presets
could be interesting you know there are
certain use cases which you've probably
got in mind and whether or not anyone
will ever actually use them it gives you
that like because this is the first
screen that you're gonna see basically
when you open this app if you know how
regions work you're not going to click
the launcher icon you're just going to
go add widget drop your two by one on
there and this is the screen you're
gonna get so this really needs to
welcome users tell them what the app
does how they're supposed to use it
which checkbox they're supposed to have
checked by default
and and make it as simple as possible
after
emphasize what you just said widgets
shares should have presets and this one
in particular I mean it's just it I
think you cover 99% of all possible
cases for this widget by just providing
5 or 10 presets absolutely from here
basically everything works is you would
kind of expect if you hit any of these
buttons it brings up a confirmation
dialog which you can skip so you can say
you know what if I want to send an
emergency message I don't want to have
to do two clicks I just want to do one
well and once again this is sort of a
it's a confusing dialogue like I've just
gone out of something that's beautiful
which is the Android home screen with
the very nice widget and now I'm looking
at this thing that you know it almost
looks like a some pirated app just took
over my screen exactly and so you want
this to be small as well we've got a
whole bunch of sort of empty space here
if you so if you're not going fullscreen
go as small as you can and make this it
is just a confirmation dialogue I've
already selected all of this stuff so
you almost want to be able to have just
a big send button and then maybe an
ability to edit as well if you want to
right you want the send button to be big
you want the information to be there but
not editable then you want to have a way
to go edit it because because by
bringing up the Edit boxes as it is now
a you're introducing possible error
where somebody accidentally hits a key
that they didn't intend to and B you're
making it seem like I have to edit it
like that's my job now is to edit this
but no I'm just telling trying to tell
lastly we're to dig to get me out from
underneath the rubble precisely I don't
need all this exactly and so this again
sort of what I really like here is
there's this ability to set a timer so
you can say you know said it five
minutes before you use then you control
fit out there it kind of moved and it's
it's really horrible it is and it's it's
a really useful function so I would
actually kind of want to have that as
the main thing so the two main things
here is I want send it now send it in a
few minutes and edit also maybe so you
almost want to in flip the importance of
those things so that the editing
functionality is up on the top right and
the being able to set a timer is right
there and also note that yeah so there's
no way to cancel here as well which is
interesting
so I've done but I changed my mind us
when I send it now I kind of can't which
is again it's just sort of that user
flow you want to make everything as
simple and easy as possible and make it
impossible for a user to
wrong it's never the right answer to say
oh you're using the app wrong that
should never even be an option so they
should only ever be able to use it right
one thing that they have done nicely
here is that one of the recipients you
can set is share with other app which is
what we've got tick now so if we do that
we can see it's set up a non going
notification which is time set to an
hour interesting I'm going to cancel
that one and set off another one really
quickly now what it's going to do is
find my current location so now all that
information we gave earlier on about
being able to find a location really
quickly becomes really important because
I don't want to sit here waiting for it
to find my GPS signal anything is good
enough right now so you can by all means
check to see whether you can get
something really accurate if it doesn't
happen within five seconds screw it go
with what you had last and send that
maybe send a second message maybe make
that an option so that's going to keep
doing its thing retrieving current
location for a while
interestingly their app comes up when
that happens as well so I think you
probably done something weird with your
intent receivers there so this shouldn't
be getting triggered from clicking on
the widget that's not a great user
experience if you want to make sure that
doesn't end up on the activity stack
associated with your activity when
you're entering it from the widget so
once that's happened you will actually
then let you send that message by any of
the other apps that you've got on the
system which is a nice you know a nice
way of doing things and in fact I guess
maybe take that as an opportunity to
talk a little bit about exactly what
they're doing there oh there it is so
that's it's now got the location and we
can share it using any of the apps which
are capable of sharing text which is
nice so hmm perhaps as we were saying
right perhaps even more so than
Foursquare low latency location
detection is absolutely critical for
this app so I'd be interested to know
from the developers what techniques
they're using to get that quick and
accurate location text particularly
because it's not that quick so I'd like
to see them doing some work to improve
that but one of the things they have
done well is this this sharing using any
app dialog which I really like and which
is something with TripIt has done pretty
well as well making use of intents to
add more functionality to their apps
without having to do any
to work so we're running out of time but
let's quickly go over what you need to
do to add this sort of share intent to
your app absolutely so let's see bloom
so the details for what I'm subscribing
here are all in this Android training
class on sharing content but the basics
are actually pretty straightforward you
can create you know all that typography
looked right on my laptop that's what
they all say if I was fine on my machine
you were so you create a new intent you
send the action set the action to send
and then populate the text extra with
the text that you want to transmit then
you just start an activity using that
intent now in this example here I'm
actually forcing the activity chooser to
be displayed every time that's because
users will often choose a default outfit
for handling a lot of content and for an
app like this you actually want to give
the the user a chance to say well which
specific things you want because you've
actually checked a box to say send using
another app kind of makes sense to give
them an opportunity to say which app
that they want so given that we are just
about out of time I think happily we're
just on to the prescriptions for GT apps
that we want to look at so let me top
all of this behind us and we'll bring
each of these up so I think this is the
this is the prescriptions for a
Foursquare I didn't have a lot because
they've done a pretty good job though
they're really hard we're pretty
impressed I mean the Foursquare team has
spent a lot of time really refining and
honing their app to try and make it as
good as possible they're really
passionate about creating a pure Android
experience something that is really user
friendly that makes the phone work
better that is you know in always a
positive and not a negative so hats off
to them indeed but as with any app that
was designed almost exclusively in the
Bay Area
it simply assumes too much about your
network connection it needs to be better
offline and also better during changing
network conditions yeah and so for me I
guess the key thing and I have brought
this up with the Foursquare team and I
know that they have good reasons for not
doing this but I'm going to mention it
anyway for anyone else who's doing an
app which does something similar is
support for being able to check in when
I'm offline so in the Bay Area going
inside ends up having better network
access because everyone has free Wi-Fi
right not the case in London and a lot
of the good venues are all like
three stories underground so that you
know they don't get bombed in the Second
World War but also means that they have
really bad network coverage and no free
Wi-Fi because nothing is free in London
so being able to check in and then just
have all of that get cashed in a queue
that then will check me into all these
places once I do get network access
would be a really nice feature so I'm
going to take this opportunity to ask
the Foursquare guys to do that again
TripIt fir but we have a couple more
suggestions for them again this is an
app that we really love and this is one
of those apps which does everything
right in terms of the service that it
provides absolutely love it totally
indispensable would use it even if it
was a terminal prompt so that means that
a lot of what we're actually saying here
is in a way it's nitpicky but it's also
something which can make the app that
much more appealing that much more fun
to use and it's I think that the key
thing here is it would be great to see
them take another pass at the design and
other parts of the UI
now that we've had these changes to holo
so kind of a UI overhaul would be kind
of nice to see so that's you know we've
got all the details there that things
like you know getting rid of the menu
button not having the click to load more
lists just having that automatically
feel as we scroll more use of c2dm
better copying and pasting and overall
cleaner navigation and an our third
contender so the the share way location
widget again I think the key here is
really a simplified workflow all right
everything should be easier particularly
the first time it should just be click
click that's my wife's contact done well
yeah we've talked about this many times
that a lot of apps are just difficult to
get into and what you need to do is just
figure out what the most common use case
is and just fill that stuff in for the
user exactly you know it seems kind of
counterintuitive in a lot of ways to say
we want you to remove some of the
options from your app but it kind of
works particularly for something like
this which is really focused is figure
out what is it that people are
downloading this app to do and you can
use analytics for that to find out what
are the most common settings that
they're choosing what are the most
common options that they're clicking and
make that not only default but maybe the
only thing that you can do and then
worry about expanding those features in
a way that's consistent with the app
usage and easier to use as time goes on
and definitely ditch the ginger
we're sorry we're sorry we ever put it
out yeah go to holo it happens but yeah
make a UI that's consistent with the
rest of the framework preferably
something that's hollow but definitely
something which doesn't feel like it's
being yanked out of an earlier phone and
stuck in the middle of your app and
that's again particularly important for
anything which is widget based because
users aren't gonna be in your app much
but when they are you don't want to make
it feel jarring so that's that's kind of
kind of an important step and also the
widget the widget is what you're doing
so make sure the widgets are really
beautiful they look
kind of Jaggi and and blurred on on on
the Galaxy Nexus so make sure you've got
the right assets nice scalable assets so
that everything looks really beautiful
because if it's going to live on the
homescreen it needs to look nice people
wants to look nice so I think that just
about takes us to the end of today's of
today's app clinic so to both a
Foursquare and TripIt of the apps that
we looked at are already featured in
Google play's Editors Choice category
which makes them a good chance to join
the pure Android collection particularly
Foursquare which you know having looked
at again today just continues to impress
so wherever possible in the future we're
going to prioritize reviewing apps by
people who self-nominated them so to be
sure so please be sure to head over to
Trello to nominate your apps and in fact
I'll stick that in the background as
well so I don't know if you can read
that I don't think what I can add to the
foreground
yeah why not let's bring it to the front
boom yes so that's a bitly / app clinic
Trello so that's where you're gonna go
to to nominate the categories that you'd
like us to review and to nominate your
apps in particular for us to take a look
at so our next week what are we looking
at next week oh if I knew I'd be a
genius what are we looking at there next
week down I'm gonna read off the screen
and say
oh it's on the screen on the side would
you pass you if I hadn't given you the
answer so gonna be choosing that later
this afternoon
so if you haven't used a messaging app
that you would like us to check out
please make sure that you've got it
nominated there so that we can you know
bring it up and talk about it next week
indeed so instant message should we
shall we narrow that down at all if you
like yeah so these are apps like Google
Talk or like I don't always a OLS or
messenger this little thing or like
Skype yeah I see cute ICQ yeah I'm gonna
go though sure so something that's gonna
allow you to type and/or voice to each
other exactly I'm particularly
interested in looking at what they call
they push-to-talk apps yeah absolutely
yeah so well there'll be it'll be an
interesting one an interesting one to
try and demo the apps as well so well we
may need to get someone another room to
help us out
guys that'll be interesting huh so
that's it for today's episode of the act
clinic but be sure to tune in next
Tuesday for Android design in action
with Roman Nick and Adam live for our
New York studios now before we sign off
I do want to ask producer Dan if we have
any questions which we should answer in
the negative 13 seconds that we have so
yeah we were we would love to answer any
questions that you guys have during the
show about the apps or about any of the
technical content or indeed just the
structure of the show given that we're
trying things a little bit differently
so do be sure to send your comments
through on Google+ in particular yes now
yeah if you if you have if you happen to
be looking at this later on remember
we've got comments open on Google+ that
you can take a look at it and all you
need to do is mention one of our names
you will see it and look at it
absolutely so we'll be back again next
week at the same time and in the
meantime we're going to be taking a look
at some of our past abkani patients to
see if any of them have attained the
status of pure Android so if you have
had your app reviewed and you've made
some changes you'd love for us to take a
look at those improvements do let us
know my name is reto Meier
i'm ian ni-lewis and thank you for
watching sure